Laisse-moi être le sale flic !
Je veux être le méchant flic !
- Je peux être le sale flic ?
- Tu peux !
Ce sera pas compliqué.
Trois nanas du club d'étudiantes.
Je te l'ai dit,
ce sera facile.
La fouille de la maison
a donné quoi ?
Pas d'arme du crime,
pas de preuves tangibles.
Merde !
Tout ce qu'on a est circonstanciel.
Donnez-moi un élément.
Sur toute cette histoire !
Peu importe.
Sûr que vous mourez d'envie
de savoir ce qui est arrivé
au club le plus fameux du campus !
Eh bien... je vais vous montrer !
Mais les garçons,
bas les pattes !
J'adore tes boucles d'oreilles !
Très bien, les filles...
Vous êtes à Omega Kappa !
Tout le monde se tait,
et se met en rang !
Vous croyez être dignes
du club "Okay" ?
À partir de maintenant,
vous vous taisez,
et vous m'écoutez !
C'est compris ?
Vous me faites gerber !
Vous êtes nulles !
C'est quoi, ce sourire ?
Content de me retrouver ?
C'est chaque fois meilleur.
Comment tu vas me séduire ?
Je pensais que c'était fait.
Ça compte pas,
c'était que du sexe.
Un sac à main "Mark Jacobs" ?
Toute la collection ?
Complète ?
Ça marche ?
Je vais me débrouiller.
T'es vraiment le meilleur !
Oh, je rêve,
c'est Lana Stevens !
Elle est fabuleuse !
Nina !
Oh, salut Lana !
Tu fais quoi, là ?
Un peu de ménage.
Je dois avoir des messages,
tu vérifies ?
Oui, bien sûr.
C'est ravissant !
J'en veux un !
Tu le porteras mieux que moi !
Merci.
C'est absolument parfait !
Quoi ?
Tu es là !
Voilà mes copines !
Mai, ton corps de rêve
est le centre du monde !
Zoey, tu es toujours très bien.
C'est vrai.
Prêtes à passer
aux choses sérieuses ?
On bouge, les filles !
Petites morveuses,
vous me suivez maintenant !
Bougez !
En marche, exécution !
Par ici, suivez-moi !
Allez-y, du rythme !
On se presse,
la fille aux talons hauts !
Oh, la molasse !
Toi, t'es une vraie bouffonne !
Ce que tu pues !
Vous êtes trop répugnantes !
Pas du tout "Okay" !
Les filles !
Mai, Zoey et moi,
on va vous regarder
carrément à la loupe.
Vous devez évaluer les filles
d'un rapide signe de main.
Souvenez-vous.
Si vous la détestez,
levez un doigt.
Si vous l'aimez,
levez la main.
Pour une évaluation plus pointue,
levez le poing.
C'est bon, on y va !
Quelle est ta couleur favorite ?
Rose pâle, rose vif !
Et ton mot préféré ?
Okay !
Mets le tout ensemble.
Rose pâle, rose vif !
Okay !
Plus fort !
Venez !
Prochain arrêt...
" Delta Pi ".
L'année dernière...
la fête de printemps
était sur une barque.
Complètement dément !
Ça paraît dingue !
Plus que dingue !
Nos fêtes sont déjantées !
Je sais.
Votre club est connu de tous
sur le campus.
On est assez légendaires !
Mai sait de quoi elle parle.
Elle est chargée
des relations sociales.
Son équipe tient la vedette,
depuis les 4 dernières années.
- Tu es mignonne.
- Merci.
Très mignonne.
- Salut, Tina .
- Bonjour, Lana !
Fanny, qui est là...
est un héritage.
Moi aussi, j'étais un héritage.
Mais pas ici.
Ma mère, ma tante
et ma grand-mère,
étaient dans un autre club.
Ce n'est pas contre
les lois grecques sacrées ?
Pas du tout.
Faut choisir le club
qui te correspond le mieux.
T'as pensé à " E.W.E " ?
Ils font des tournois d'échecs
hebdomadaires.
T'aimes les échecs ?
J'adore.
En fait, je me classais en tête...
dans les tournois
scolaires nationaux.
Ils discutent aussi
de sujets importants, comme...
le réchauffement de la planète.
C'est vrai ?
Alors...
tu ne serais pas vexée...
si j'allais me renseigner ?
Pas le moins du monde.
Tu es faite pour ce club.
Merci.
Faut que tu voies Zoey,
notre responsable du sport.
Oh, Zoey !
Je te présente Emily.
On dirait que tu es entraînée.
Arts martiaux
deux fois la semaine.
Vraiment ?
J'ai fait ça l'an dernier.
C'est vrai ?
Oui.
J'enseigne une méthode
de kickboxing sculptural.
Tu devrais venir voir.
C'est ma jolie poupée !
Vous vous connaissez ?
Emily est mon coach vocal.
On s'exerce ensemble
pour nos "Oh" et nos "Ah" !
Elle n'est pas la plus adorable ?
Tu participes à la fête demain ?
Non...
Je crois que je vais étudier.
Le devoir m'appelle.
Salut les filles !
Je suis Lana Stevens,
présidente du club
"Omega Kappa".
Je vous remercie toutes...
d'être venues à notre club.
Nous avons
un groupe de filles super ici.
C'est pas juste pour les fêtes,
et trouver des garçons,
mais pour ce que je ressens
en rentrant...
d'une journée
de cours lamentable,
et que je m'assieds sur le canapé
avec mes soeurs.
C'est si doux et plein d'amour,
que je me sens bénie
de m'éveiller ici chaque jour.
Je vous souhaite
bonne chance à toutes.
C'est une semaine difficile,
mais écoutez votre coeur,
et vous trouverez le bon club.
Tout comme moi.
Merci !
Mes soeurs...
C'est la décision
la plus importante de notre vie !
Maintenant...
qui peut dire trois mots
de Megan Woods ?
Drôle, du cran, jolie.
Excellent !
Mais souviens-toi...
Même si nous n'acceptons
que des physiques exceptionnels,
ça n'entre pas en compte
dans nos critères.
Seuls les traits de personnalité
sont retenus selon nos conventions.
Compris ?
Désolée, Lana...
Ça donne:
drôle, du cran, et...
agréable... à regarder.
C'est mieux !
Prenez vos raquettes pour voter.
Acceptée à l'unanimité !
Fanny Applebaum.
Quelle grosse vache !
Pas vrai ?
Je crois pouvoir dire
qu'elle serait mieux ailleurs.
Elle serait mieux ailleurs !
Ma chouchoute !
Emily Barton.
Emily est fantastique !
Feu vert pour Emily !
Une petite seconde !
J'admets qu'Emily est parfaite,
mais notre équipe de recrutement
vient de découvrir...
que son niveau en grec
est très faible.
Je crains
qu'on ne puisse l'admettre.
Ce que dit Zoey est hélas vrai.
Elle représente un risque.
Cependant...
selon notre livre de loi,
page 268, 2ème partie,
paragraphe "5-A"...
si une héritière renonce
à son droit,
Emily pourra directement
entrer à sa place.
Tu es un petit génie, Lana !
Procédons au vote officiel
de Melle Barton.
Parfait !
Demain,
on anime notre fête annuelle.
Soyez super gentilles
avec les très belles filles.
Bien sûr !
Enfin...
une dernière chose.
Si quoi que ce soit de "louche"
se passe à cette fête,
"Omega Kappa" sera dissous,
et quittera le campus.
Ce sera la fin pour nous.
La séance est levée !
Nina ?
Je peux faire quoi avec ça ?
Je suis désolée.
J'ai eu une dure semaine,
avec l'organisation de la fête.
C'est moi qui ai le plus à faire !
Tu me déçois beaucoup.
J'ai hâte que la semaine finisse
pour avoir nos filles.
Ça a été trop stressant !
Je sais !
Je n'ai pu m'entraîner
que deux fois par jour !
C'est sûrement le tonneau !
Je sais pas qui c'est.
Laisse, je m'en occupe.
Bonjour, les filles !
Je suis Katherine Wittington.
" Omega Kappa ", 1 984 !
Bienvenue, Melle Wittington.
Lana Stevens,
présidente du club !
le portrait craché de votre mère !
Cindy était ma Grande Soeur !
Il faut que je vous embrasse !
Il est temps
de vous présenter ma fille.
Katie, viens rencontrer les filles !
Allons Katie,
ne sois pas timide !
Fais connaissance
avec tes futures soeurs !
Voici Lana.
Et... heu...
Mai !
Bonjour, Katie.
Ravie de te connaître !
Bonjour.
- Zoey.
- Ravie de te connaître.
Dommage que tu aies raté
les évaluations.
C'est ma faute.
Réunion familiale !
Ça m'excite trop d'être ici !
J'ai fait des recherches sur le club
pendant tout le semestre.
J'ai même pris
un appareil dentaire rose !
Et vous les filles,
vous êtes "Okay " !
Très juste !
Vous êtes bien des amies
de Rachel Winters ?
- Non, je ne...
- Tu dis Rachel Winters ?
- Oui, elle m'a dit que...
- Katie, je parle !
Si on montrait à Katie
le " Mur de la Gloire " ?
Elle meurt d'envie
de voir sa maman à cette époque.
C'est naturel !
Par ici.
Vous ne trouvez pas
que je suis exactement la même ?
Oui...
On peut parler un petit moment ?
Bien sûr.
Ta maman est très jolie.
Écoutez...
je sais que ma Katie
n'a pas vraiment le profil du club,
mais je compte sur vous,
en tant que fille
de ma Grande Soeur,
pour qu'elle devienne
une " Omega Kappa " comme nous.
Vous ne pensez pas
qu'elle serait mieux ailleurs ?
Je vous en prie !
Cette phrase est de moi !
Quand Katie intégrera le club,
elle s'épanouira en femme
aussi magnifique que moi.
Et que vous !
Melle Wittington...
avec tout le respect
que je vous dois,
vous ne pensez pas sérieusement
qu'elle se plairait ici ?
Ce doit être une gentille fille,
mais elle serait rejetée
par les autres !
Vous allez...
prendre ma Katie sous votre aile,
et vous arranger...
pour que les filles...
la traitent correctement.
Il me suffit de passer un coup de fil
à l'Association,
et vous êtes virée de ce club.
- Vous n'oseriez pas !
- Essayez !
Je donne des milliers de dollars
chaque année,
et votre mère
n'a jamais donné un cent.
Elle ne s'est jamais souciée
que d'elle-même !
Elle traînait toute la journée
en pyjama, comme vous.
Alors...
allez-vous faire le bon choix ?
En qualité de "Kappa"...
je vous donne ma parole.
Aussi intelligente que jolie.
Merci.
Salope !
J'aime sa chevelure.
J'ai à peu près la même !
Oui...
Faites-vous toujours
" La fête jusqu'à l'ivresse " ?
On n'a pas manqué
une seule année !
Katie devra être au lit à 9 heures.
Très bien.
Il faut qu'on s'en aille.
Oh, déjà ?
Oui, des bagages à préparer.
Week-end aux Caraïbes
avec mon nouveau petit mari !
Rose pâle, rose vif...
le coeur des garçons chavire !
On est des "Omega Kappa",
pas un ne nous résiste !
On est "Okay" !
Ce qu'elle doit engloutir !
J'ai pris 1 kilo
rien qu'en l'approchant !
Faites-moi confiance.
Salut, bébé !
Bonjour, ma belle !
Toujours partant
pour un avant-goût de la fête ?
Plus que jamais, bébé !
Alors, à plus tard.
Je t'aime !
Ouais...
James, faut que j'aille
vérifier le système.
Rassemble un maximum de DVD
chez les garçons.
Pour quoi faire ?
Mon pote !
Dis à notre jeune protégé
ce qu'on va faire des DVD.
Avec plaisir, monsieur !
Notre génie va se filmer...
en pleine action
avec sa copine ultra chaude !
Je la baise,
et je rapporte les cassettes.
Il me les refile,
on les charge dans l'ordinateur,
on grave quelques copies,
et on les vend...
pour un bon paquet de fric !
Et c'est dans la poche !
Les gens vont acheter ?
Mec, c'est Lana Stevens !
Elle est plutôt...
portée sur la chose...
et j'aimerais bien y avoir droit !
Non !
J'en ai vendu à des 1ère année,
et sans blaguer...
cette nuit,
on arrose tout le campus !
C'est une idée géniale !
Tu veux que je te dise ?
On va se faire du blé
avec ses " Oh, bébé " !
Super, mec !
Oui...
t'es géniale !
Dis-moi comme c'est bon !
Tu sais que je déteste parler !
Dis-le moi !
T'es trop bon !
Crie mon nom !
Jeff... Jeff...
t'es trop doué !
Tu es bonne !
Faut que tu m'aides ce soir.
Je peux faire quoi ?
Il y aura cette affreuse héritière.
Katie.
Je veux que tu sois
absolument odieux.
Que cette nuit
soit un enfer pour elle !
C'est quoi, ça ?
Bébé...
tu es une déesse.
Je ferais n'importe quoi pour toi.
Tu disais quoi ?
Je ne sais plus.
Attends, tu pars ?
Faut que j'y aille.
Faut que je garde
un peu de forces !
On y va, les filles !
Je suis tellement contente
que tu aies pu venir !
Ça m'excite trop d'être là !
C'est ma première
vraie soirée d'étudiants.
C'est vraiment trop mignon !
Excusez-moi,
faut que je monte un instant.
Bien sûr !
Maman a déliré sur cette fête
toute la journée.
Elle m'a même acheté
une nouvelle tenue.
C'est pas joli ?
Absolument ravissant !
Excuse-moi.
Faut que je voie d'autres filles.
Une présidente
a toujours à faire !
Zoey se fera une joie
de te présenter à nos soeurs.
N'est-ce pas, Zoey ?
Evidemment.
Amuse-toi bien.
Merci.
J'ai besoin d'un verre !
Je te présente
ma copine Stevie.
Elle est complètement "OK" aussi !
Formidable !
Bienvenue, Stevie !
Si tu es moitié aussi sympa
que le dit Emmy,
et déjà tu es moitié...
je veux dire... totalement,
aussi jolie qu'elle dit...
je suis certaine que tu adoreras
être une "OK" !
Bière à l'entonnoir, Emily !
Qui veut me voir faire ?
Vas-y, petite soeur !
Salut, Matty !
Zoey, salut bébé !
Superbe, comme toujours !
T'es pas mal non plus !
C'est quoi, ça ?
C'est personne !
4 verres, s'il te plaît ?
Quelle couleur ?
N'importe, le plus fort !
J'adore les sacs "Prada",
mais tout le monde en a,
alors j'ai pensé à un "Gucci",
mais une fille
avait celui que je voulais !
Alors je me suis décidée
pour celui-ci.
C'est un "L.V."
Personne n'en a encore,
car il est hors de prix !
Il est magnifique !
Je crois que Lana a le même.
C'est bon pour l'instant !
Je n'ai jamais bu de ma vie !
Pour être "OK",
c'est obligatoire !
Pas vrai, les amis ?
Et pour une "bleue",
c'est double dose.
Emily, tu es là !
- C'est la soirée la plus géniale !
- Je sais !
Emily, je te présente Matty.
C'est un "Sigma".
Enchanté !
Bonsoir.
- Dommage !
- Oh, c'est rien !
Le genre de chose qui arrive !
Vous voulez jouer
à "Vérité ou défi" ?
- Absolument !
- Je commence !
- Vérité ou défi ?
- Choisis le défi !
Très bien ! Défi.
Je te défie de m'embrasser.
Embrasser une soeur
est un billet d'entrée.
Je veux aussi mon billet !
Et moi, alors ?
Embrassez-vous, ça compte aussi.
Tu dois être Katie ?
Je te cherchais.
Emily fait partie des nôtres.
Je suis trop contente
de te connaître !
Il paraît que
tu as ta place réservée.
Je veux pas entrer
juste parce que je suis héritière.
J'aime le club "Omega Kappa",
et tout ce qu'il signifie !
Viens prendre une bière.
- Ma tête commence à tourner !
- T'en fais pas, viens !
Tu vas bien regarder
comment je fais.
Après, tu essaieras
de battre mon record !
Désolée les filles,
il faut que je rentre !
Allons-y !
Ça va, ma belle ?
- Un problème à régler !
- Courage !
Il se fiche de moi ?
Je vais te dire...
c'est très réussi !
Excuse-moi ?
Tu fais quoi, là ?
Nicole est postulante, et...
elle me montrait que...
le nouveau silicone...
donnait un toucher très naturel !
C'est extra !
- Pourquoi ?
- Embrasser ces salopes !
C'est une sélection !
Je leur fais juste
passer du bon temps !
Je t'avais dit d'être sympa,
pas de les allumer !
Si vous alliez retrouver Emily
au tonneau de bière ?
Faut que je discute avec Jeff.
- Pourquoi t'es là ?
- Fallait que je te voie !
Je t'avais dit de pas venir,
surtout ce soir !
Tu me manques,
je t'ai pas vue de la semaine !
Je suis juste amical.
Tu peux pas flirter
avec les candidates !
De quoi j'ai l'air ?
Je suis la présidente du club,
et mon copain est infidèle !
Je t'avais dit
que j'étais coincée au club !
Je veux plus de cette vie !
Je veux passer ma dernière année
avec ma copine !
J'en ai marre qu'on se cache !
Ma chambre te plaît ?
Énormément !
C'est douillet !
Merci.
Viens sur moi !
Prête, ma belle ?
Pourquoi tu manques
autant d'assurance ?
Je ne manque pas d'assurance,
et tu pourrais
mieux apprécier le fait...
de sortir avec la fille
la plus populaire du campus !
Tu peux pas t'élever
un peu au-dessus...
de ton petit club de pacotille ?
J'en ai vraiment marre de toi !
Je m'en fous !
Petite idiote rose !
Tu te fous de moi ?
Laisse-moi 2 petites secondes,
et je remets le couvert.
T'es même pas capable de bander
pendant une minute ?
Tu pourrais...
m'apporter une bière ?
Va te faire voir !
Un arc-en-ciel !
Un arc-en-ciel ?
T'es sûre que ça va ?
Oui... très bien !
En place pour le catch !
Tu devrais y aller.
Ça impressionnerait les filles !
- Vraiment ?
- Absolument.
Amuse-toi !
Allez Katie !
Montre-nous tes talents !
Allez, les filles !
C'est des culottes de grand-mère !
Elle est trop affreuse !
Lana, Jeff te cherche.
Il a l'air en rogne !
Ça va, toi ?
Tu veux quoi ?
Faut qu'on parle !
- Je suis occupée.
- Non, maintenant !
Je suis occupée !
Y a un événement dehors.
- J'ai pas de temps pour toi !
- Comme d'habitude !
- C'est reparti !
- Tu ne penses qu'à ton club !
Tu ne parles que de ça !
Comme ton club est super !
Quelle super présidente tu es !
Et les nouvelles recrues
qui seront merveilleuses !
Tu te calmes !
C'est pas le moment
de discuter de ça !
Il vaudrait mieux,
ou je me casse !
Très bien !
Va-t-en !
J'ai l'air contrariée ?
- Parfait !
- Absolument !
- Tout est fini !
- Eh bien... tant mieux !
Cette nana, j'y crois pas !
Le pire, c'est qu'elle pourrait
entrer au club !
Pas question
d'être dans sa classe !
Les filles !
Ma parole qu'elle n'entrera pas.
C'est bon !
Tu t'es un peu trop amusée !
Sors de là !... Dépêche-toi !
Allez viens !
Avance !... Avance !
Vas-y, la grosse !
Allez...
enfile ça.
On y va !
Les affreuses chaussures !
Reste ici
jusqu'à ce que je revienne,
et tâche de dessoûler !
T'es un vrai désastre !
Où est l'autre bout ?
Dommage que t'aies passé
une si mauvaise soirée.
Je suppose
que tu veux plus rester.
Tu rigoles ?
Je me suis tellement marrée !
C'est la plus belle soirée
de ma vie !
J'adore " Omega Kappa " !
T'es sérieuse ?
Absolument.
Génial !
Quelle magnifique invention
de Dieu !...
Le beignet.
Le beignet... oui !
On a quoi ce soir ?
On va faire un tour
au club "Omega Kappa"...
jeter un coup d'oeil
sur ces nanas.
Pour s'assurer...
qu'elles se tiennent bien.
C'est pas drôle.
L'abus d'alcool est un fléau chronique
sur les campus.
T'as marqué un point.
Si on veut maintenir l'ordre
sur ce campus,
leur protection
est notre priorité première.
L'alcool étant un tel problème,
on va entrer dans cette maison,
confisquer les bouteilles,
pour leur propre sécurité !
Bien vu, mec !
Pour leur propre sécurité !
Excellent, mec !
- Donne-moi ça.
- Qu'est-ce que...?
C'est à moi.
T'es un tyran !
Oui, je suis un tyran.
Et toi, un crétin !
Est-ce que tout va bien ?
Parfaitement bien.
- Va chercher Mai et Zoey.
- D'accord.
Lana t'appelle dans sa chambre.
- Rentre vite !
- Merde !
Lana te demande
dans sa chambre.
La sécurité arrive !
Alors, videz les lieux !
Tout de suite !
Merde !
Tout le monde dehors !
On fait quoi ?
On cache le corps ?
Je ne touche pas ce gros tas !
Mon club fermera pas
à cause de cette grosse gourde !
On la soulève !
La porte est ouverte !
- Merde, elle m'a échappé !
- Comment ça ?
Allons-y !
Pas au sous-sol !
C'est là qu'ils vont d'abord !
Là-dedans !
- T'es sûre qu'elle va tenir ?
- Je sais pas, aide-moi !
Je savais
qu'elle viderait notre frigo,
mais pas de cette façon !
Aidez-moi pour la clayette !
- Elle est trop grosse !
- Non, fourre-la dedans !
C'est bon !
On a pas le temps !
On la fourre dans le placard !
- C'est quoi, ça ?
- Super tactique !
Lâche-moi, pervers !
- Dégage !
- Quoi ?
Lâche-moi !
Bas les pattes !
Ça va ?
Tout va bien ?
C'était un bélier
un peu trop lourd pour moi !
Ça, j'ai du mal à le croire !
Je suis Lana Stevens.
La présidente de "OK".
Que puis-je pour vous ?
Eh bien...
Je suis l'officier Jaul,
et l'officier Santocki,
et nous sommes là...
pour faire cesser la fête.
En ce cas...
vous avez fait du bon boulot !
Oui...
on le dirait bien !
Eh bien, je crois qu'on peut...
tout est net, vous pouvez...
en être quitte
pour un petit avertissement.
Ça vous va ?
Alors très bien !
On a quoi, là ?
Je vais devoir la confisquer !
Ces crétins de garçons
ont dû l'apporter.
D'après vous,
ils sont tous partis ?
Attendez !
Mesdemoiselles !
Vous avez de graves ennuis !
Bougez de là !
Allez !
- Pas de bière fraîche ?
- Pas d'alcool dans cette maison.
Contre notre politique.
Ouais...
Pas d'alcool ?
Et ça ?
Poussez-vous.
Dégagez !
Par ici !
Bordel !
Vous voyez...
Y a pas d'alcool.
On a un homicide
au club "Omega Kappa".
Et voilà comment on a atterri ici.
Plutôt débile, non ?
Nous coincer
dans ce poste de police,
n'est qu'une perte
de notre temps si précieux.
De plus, les "soeurs OK"...
sont parfaitement capables
de tenir leur club en ordre.
Vous êtes chargé du sale boulot ?
Inspecteur Richards,
et voici l'inspecteur Sams.
Zoey Martin ?
J'ai de mauvaises nouvelles.
Ma séance de sauna de 7 heures
est annulée ?
Très drôle, mais...
dans votre situation,
j'éviterais ce genre de blagues.
Je ne blague pas.
Moi non plus.
Vous avez des sujets d'inquiétude
beaucoup plus sérieux !
Pourquoi ?
Je n'ai rien à me reprocher.
Ce n'est pas l'avis de vos "soeurs"
Mai et Lana.
Elles vous ont désignée la meurtrière
en moins de 2 minutes.
Nouveau record,
pas vrai, Sams ?
Voilà ce qu'on appelle
de la loyauté !
- Elles le savent !
- Quoi ?
Que je suis "bi".
Bisexuelle ?
Linguale !
Rien de plus.
Je n'ai pas tué cette Katie.
Vous prétendez n'avoir rien fait ?
J'ai rien à voir avec ça !
Je peux dire exactement où j'étais,
durant toute la soirée.
Je vous écoute.
Katie est arrivée trop tôt.
Je n'avais pas fait
le tour de mes invités, donc...
j'ai demandé à Zoey
de s'occuper d'elle.
Zoey se fera une joie
de te présenter à nos soeurs.
N'est-ce pas, Zoey ?
Je la supposais
en de bonnes mains.
C'est ma première
vraie soirée d'étudiants !
Amuse-toi bien.
Je n'ai vu Katie qu'une minute
quand elle est arrivée.
Je devais monter
voir d'autres filles.
- À plus tard, Katie !
- D'accord.
Vous êtes accusée de meurtre
au premier degré !
La question
que vous devez vous poser est:
allez-vous passer
le reste de votre vie en prison ?
Ou sur la chaise électrique ?
Pourquoi ?
Parce que cette hypocrite
m'a accusée ?
une simple question,
jeune fille.
Avez-vous déjà vu de la fumée...
sans qu'il y ait du feu ?
De quelle hypocrite parliez-vous ?
Lana !
Elle était si contrariée
d'accueillir cette fille !
Selon les témoins...
Katie Wittington est arrivée...
à 21 heures.
Autrement dit à 9 heures du soir.
Démarrez de là.
Je voulais que Katie
passe une bonne soirée.
J'ai besoin d'un verre !
Je l'ai prise avec moi
pour la présenter.
- Salut, ma belle !
- C'est Matty.
Je suis trop contente
de te connaître !
Nous savons
que vous ne vouliez pas d'elle.
Et vous aviez un plan.
Quel plan ?
Faites en sorte que Katie
vive un cauchemar.
Il faut qu'elle se sente ridicule,
et qu'elle le soit !
Tous les coups sont permis
pour qu'elle renonce.
Vraiment tous ?
Absolument.
Je nous trouve adorables !
Vos deux acolytes
nous ont tout dit.
Dans le détail !
Je ne vous crois pas.
Zoey nous a dit
que vous vouliez Emily,
et Katie faisait obstacle.
Quelle ingrate !
Vous prétendez n'avoir rien fait ?
J'ai dit à Emily que je l'adorais,
et rêvais qu'elle nous rejoigne.
Il y a cette gourde de Katie,
c'est une héritière importante,
et je crains
qu'à cause de tes notes...
elle te pique la place.
Tu plaisantes ?
Elle est la plus jolie
représentation de moi-même !
C'est laquelle ?
Je m'en occupe.
Où était Katie ?
Je crois l'avoir vue
boire des verres avec Zoey.
Je lui ai dit...
qu'elle n'était pas obligée,
si ça ne lui plaisait pas.
Elle a tout avalé d'un trait !
T'es pas soûle ?
C'était choquant.
Notre club n'excuse pas
l'ivresse sur mineures !
Viens prendre une bière !
Où sont-elles allées ?
Comment je le saurais ?
Elle se faisait des amis.
Des amis ?
Amicaux jusqu'à quel point ?
En tous cas,
ce que j'ai vu ensuite...
À ton tour !
Vous avez laissé Katie
dans cet état ?
Oui...
mais elle semblait s'amuser !
J'ai glissé.
Ta tête, ça va ?
J'ai vu Katie sortir
quand je parlais avec mon amie.
Elle paraissait en triste état.
Pas mal ivre.
Je crois même qu'elle a vomi.
Salut, Rachel !
Je le savais !
J'ai vérifié si elle allait bien.
Rentre, on reparlera de tout ça !
Écoute bien !
Personne n'est au courant
pour Rachel et moi.
Pourquoi ?
Y a pas de mal à s'aimer !
Tiens ta langue !
Tu ne devrais même pas
être à cette fête !
Sans ta mère,
tu serais pas là !
Je sais...
- mais je pensais que...
- Ne pense rien !
Tu prononces une fois
les noms Rachel et Mai,
dans une même phrase...
et je te tue ! Compris ?
Oui...
Je lui ai expliqué
qu'elle avait trop bu,
et qu'elle ne devrait pas
traîner dehors.
Qu'elle serait mieux à l'intérieur,
si elle voulait se faire des amis.
Un laideron s'est fait tuer !
Un véritable "boudin" !
Hé là !... Doucement !
Quand j'ai revu Katie après,
je discutais
de techniques de sport avec Chris.
Zoey, je peux te parler ?
- Je vous laisse.
- Attends !
Et moi alors ?
Katie...
T'as les lèvres un peu sèches !
Essaie ça.
Merci.
Ça a le goût d'un timbre poste !
C'est une nouvelle sorte
de protéine.
Je commence à penser que...
certaines filles
ne m'aiment pas beaucoup.
J'ai besoin d'un conseil
de ma Grande Soeur !
Pardon ?
Maman a dit que tu seras
sans doute ma Grande Soeur,
et j'ai besoin de toi tout de suite.
Pourquoi je serais
ta Grande Soeur,
espèce de grosse godiche ?
C'est vraiment méchant
ce que tu as dit !
C'est pas ma faute
si je suis moche,
si je suis pas née
jolie comme toi !
Tu crois que je suis née jolie ?
Ce corps m'a coûté
beaucoup d'efforts !
Tu sais combien de purges
j'ai dû prendre,
et le temps
que j'ai passé au sport ?
Les gros sont tous les mêmes !
Trop paresseux
pour se botter le train !
Je méprise les gens comme toi !
Je croyais que tu m'aimais bien !
Tu te trompais.
Lana, j'en ai marre.
Occupe-toi d'elle.
Et ensuite ?
J'étais un peu ennuyée
qu'elle ait déjà trop bu.
On aurait dit qu'elle avait bu
avant de venir !
Ne pleure pas !
Tu peux supporter un verre !
C'est bon.
Je ferais mieux de rentrer.
Après, elle a insisté
pour boire encore.
Alors, j'ai laissé tomber !
Nina !
Voilà 4 "bleus" !
Je crois que je peux plus boire !
Toutes les filles "OK"
font la fête !
C'est ce que ta mère faisait.
Cul-sec les deux !
En place pour le catch !
Un match de catch ?
C'est un rituel de bienvenue
que j'ai moi-même instauré.
Tout le monde adore !
Et c'est un vrai match de catch ?
Bien entendu !
Ça a de l'importance ?
Votre mère
doit être fière de vous !
Elle l'est !
Vous avez donc emmené Katie
au match de catch ?
C'est à ne pas manquer !
Ce que vous êtes brutales !
C'était super.
Et le public participait bien !
C'était...
sympa...
et drôle !
Katie s'y amusait un peu trop.
On prenait tous plaisir
à regarder le match.
Puis, Lana l'a sortie du ring,
et ramenée à la maison.
Elle était totalement ivre !
Ça donnait
une mauvaise image de nous !
Et vous l'avez arrachée à Lana,
et sauvagement assassinée !
Vous croyez ça ?
C'est alors que vous avez décidé
de la tuer !
Il devient rouge !
Vous avez emmené Katie
dans votre chambre.
Je vous l'ai dit,
pour qu'elle se dégrise !
Elles sont donc montées ?
Je n'en suis pas sûre,
parce qu'à ce moment-là...
Chris et James...
m'ont demandé l'autorisation
de monter dans ma chambre.
Tous les deux ?
Oui, nous sommes tous amis.
Vous êtes tous amis !
Où êtes-vous allée
après l'avoir quittée ?
Je suis sortie prendre l'air
dans la cour.
Ça va pas, Mai ?
C'est rien.
Ça ira après un verre.
Ça a été plutôt rapide.
T'es trop soûl ?
Faut que tu partes.
Et toi aussi. Lève-toi !
Lève-toi !
Hey, soûlard ! Debout !
Ils n'étaient pas en grande forme.
Fichez le camp !
Ensuite, qu'avez-vous fait ?
- Je suis allée dans ma chambre...
- Pour tuer Katie !
Pour que votre précieuse Emily...
puisse entrer au club !
Je suis remontée
pour voir si elle allait bien !
Katie est sur le ring.
C'est à se tordre de rire !
- Elle doit se sentir ridicule !
- Je sais.
- Tu as vu Zoey ?
- Non.
En arrivant à ma chambre,
j'ai trouvé ça bizarre,
ma porte était ouverte.
En ne la voyant pas sur le lit,
j'ai été vexée,
j'ai cru qu'elle était partie
sans me dire au revoir.
Hey, soûlarde !
Sors d'ici !
Sors de ma chambre !
Va-t-en !
Vous avez découvert le corps ?
C'est ça !
J'ai terminé !
Ce n'est pas fini !
Je veux clarifier une chose.
Allez-y !
Après avoir quitté le catch,
vous êtes rentrée,
et Nina est venue vous trouver ?
C'est ce que j'ai dit.
Qu'avez-vous fait avant...
qu'elle ne vous trouve ?
Je "broyais du noir".
Ah oui ?
Personne ne peut donc dire
où vous étiez à l'heure du crime ?
- Non.
- Vous avez déplacé le corps !
- Elle l'a tuée !
- Arrête !
J'ai pensé que c'était Lana.
Ou bien Zoey.
Lana a voulu
qu'on déplace le corps,
et Zoey n'a pas bronché,
alors j'ai suivi.
Je ne voulais pas
qu'elles aient des ennuis.
Comprenez ?
Restez ici.
On revient.
- Avez-vous déjà avalé...
- On y va, Sams !
Je suis entrée dans la chambre,
et là, j'ai vu Katie, morte.
On a entendu les flics arriver,
alors il fallait
qu'on cache le corps.
Vous l'avez déplacé ?
Obstruction à la justice !
Lana a dit que le club fermerait
si on la trouvait !
Vous n'avez pas froid aux yeux,
jeune fille !
Vous êtes dans de sales draps.
Très sales.
Très sales !
Je pourrais avoir...
un magazine, par hasard ?
En voyant Katie,
j'ai été complètement perdue !
Je ne savais pas quoi faire !
Quel spectacle !
Oui, c'est bon !
Vous êtes qui ?
Les questions, c'est moi !
Sortons !
- Quelles règles ?
- Pour résoudre l'affaire.
Vous êtes une paire de crétins
homogénéisés de première classe !
- Homogénéisé, c'est quoi ?
- Un lait !
Ça, un interrogatoire ?
"J'essaie juste de savoir
si vous l'avez tuée" !
J'ai pas dit ça comme ça.
Je l'ai dit comme ça.
Dans la poche revolver.
Le bouton a sauté !
J'y arrive pas !
Vous savez l'importance
de cette affaire ?
C'est une affaire sérieuse.
De premier ordre.
Ça vous fait rire ?
Faites m'en profiter...
si c'est si drôle !
On a une meurtrière ici,
alors si ça vous fait rire...
dites-le moi tout de suite !
Je ne vois pas
ce que tuer a de drôle !
C'est pour ça que je suis flic !
- C'est pas ça...
- Pour arrêter les tueurs !
Vous trouvez ça marrant ?
- J'étais près de...
- On a une criminelle ici !
Une putain de tueuse là-dedans !
Vous voulez les criminels
en liberté ?
On va laisser une criminelle
Elle, c'est une criminelle ?
On va la laisser en liberté ?
Vous les jeunes flics,
vous débarquez en vous prenant
pour des putains
de "Starsky et Hutch" !
C'est pas un jeu !
Il y a eu meurtre !
Une gamine est morte !
Et vous glandez !
Vous glandez comme une paire
de sombres abrutis !
Je vous jure...
devant Dieu...
que vous foirerez plus
un interrogatoire !
- J'étais sur le point...
- Vous dites ?
J'étais à ça d'aboutir !
Vous voulez
me faire sauter la cervelle ?
Vous voulez voir ça ?
Sûr que oui !
Vous voulez me voir
faire sauter la cervelle !
Vous me donnez envie
de me faire sauter la cervelle !
Sur-le-champ !
Si vous faisiez un boulot
à votre portée ?
J'ai fini, ou quoi ?
Silence !
On a trouvé un cadavre
dans votre chambre.
Vos amies sont vite arrivées
sur les lieux.
Comment ?
Nina, qui est un peu
notre bonne à tout faire,
a essayé de pointer son nez !
- Est-ce que tout va bien ?
- Parfaitement bien.
Vous aviez peur
qu'elle voie le corps ?
Je ne l'ai pas laissée entrer.
Vous lui avez caché.
Non !
Je ne voulais pas créer la panique !
Va chercher Mai et Zoey !
Ce n'est pas possible !
Je lui ai demandé
de faire monter Mai et Zoey.
On peut compter sur Nina.
Vous avez conclu
que la meilleure option...
devant cette situation,
était de déplacer le corps.
Je sais que c'était stupide.
J'étais triste, aussi !
Mais je ne pensais
qu'à la fermeture du club !
Merci, Melle Stevens.
Ça me suffit.
Il est fort.
Le meilleur !
Vous êtes très clairement
une sociopathe...
uniquement préoccupée
de votre image.
Une jeune fille est morte !
Dans votre chambre.
Écoutez, monsieur l'inspecteur...
je n'ai peut-être pas pris
la meilleure décision,
mais si j'ai raison...
ce qui est toujours le cas...
je ne suis pas
en état d'arrestation,
je peux donc partir
quand je le désire,
et je veux partir !
Maintenant !
Espèce de garce !
On va devoir les relâcher.
Quoi ?
Seul moyen
pour découvrir la vérité.
On les harcèle
jusqu'à ce qu'elles craquent !
Envoyez ces dingues
de Webb et Suhart au club.
Qu'ils tiennent ces filles à l'oeil !
Compris !
On va vous relâcher.
Le temps de trouver les preuves
pour vous condamner.
Et ce sera la chaise électrique !
Pour vous toutes.
On va épier
chacun de vos gestes.
Vous n'aurez plus le moindre
instant d'intimité.
Vous serez traquées
jusque dans les toilettes !
Vous êtes malade !
Prenez pas trop vos aises !
C'est très loin d'être terminé !
Comment vous avez osé m'accuser ?
Vous faites quoi de la loyauté ?
Quoi ?
Vous m'avez désignée
comme la tueuse !
Tu me dégoûtes !
Tu étais mon amie !
Et toi, tu n'as pas honte ?
- Tu étais ma meilleure amie !
- La ferme, Zoey !
C'est toi qui devrais avoir honte !
Tu sais que j'ai tué personne.
C'est vrai que t'as passé la nuit
à te faire sauter !
Tu serais encore un "gros cul"
si j'avais pas été là !
C'est toi qui peux pas
avaler les pilules diététiques !
Ton amitié doit être
aussi fausse que tes seins !
Tu sais très bien qu'ils sont vrais !
T'es jalouse parce que les tiens
sont minuscules !
Va te faire voir !
T'es une belle garce, Mai !
Une garce, ou une salope ?
C'est quoi le mieux ?
Tu t'es tapée combien de mecs ?
T'as perdu le compte ?
Ça suffit !
Ça va pas nous aider !
Réfléchissons un peu.
Ces inspecteurs
nous ont dit la même chose.
Ils nous ont monté un bateau !
On est tombées
dans le panneau !
C'est grotesque !
Rose pâle, rose vif,
le coeur des garçons chavire !
Tu crois ?
Allez, on chante ensemble !
Mai, c'est un ordre !
Pardon les filles,
je suis désolée...
d'avoir pu douter de vous
une seconde.
Je m'excuse aussi,
et Mai...
désolée de t'avoir
traitée de garce !
Je m'excuse.
Zoey, j'ai trop honte
de t'avoir traitée de salope.
Merci.
Excellents "Mea Culpas".
Le moyen de s'en sortir
est de rester solidaires.
Ces chers flics
ne nous lâcheront pas,
tant qu'on leur aura pas
livré de tueur !
Alors, faut réfléchir.
Ce n'est pas l'une de nous.
Abrutis de flics !
Comme si j'allais tacher
mes chaussures de sang !
Qui aurait intérêt
à tuer une telle cruche ?
Elle était vraiment boulotte !
Je te confirme.
- C'est vrai, mais on se calme !
- Salut les filles !
C'est bon de vous voir de retour.
Bonjour, salopard !
T'as même pas
répondu à mon appel !
- Et j'avais droit qu'à un seul !
- Désolé, je dormais.
On peut aller discuter
dans ta chambre ?
S'il te plaît !
- Il veut juste baiser !
- La ferme, salope !
Ça va être vite fait.
Je veux revenir avec toi.
Encore une fois ?
C'est fini Jeff,
j'en ai marre !
Tu me largues,
tu réponds pas à mon appel !
Tu te fiches de la situation
où je suis !
Je suis désolé, bébé.
Je sais que je me suis conduit
comme un imbécile,
mais je voulais pas ça !
Ça intéresse qui
comment cette fille est morte ?
Tu voulais pas d'elle ici !
C'est pas la question.
Arrête, je suis pas d'humeur.
Tu connais mon point faible !
Tu te sens bien ?
Juste une petite crampe.
Là, c'est bon.
- Tu fais quoi ?
- Je m'étire !
C'est bon !
J'ai oublié de dire à James
d'enregistrer le match !
Appelle-le sur mon portable.
Faut que j'y aille,
j'ai misé beaucoup d'argent.
Maintenant ?
J'ai mal à la tête !
Réfléchir comme ça
me tape sur les nerfs.
Arrêtez de vous plaindre.
Faut vraiment
qu'on trouve une idée.
On peut pas laisser
ternir nos noms.
Tu as raison.
On se fait une chanson "OK"
pour se mettre en train ?
Sauvée par la petite nouvelle !
Je suis passée plus tôt,
mais y avait personne.
J'étais tellement
embêtée pour vous !
Ça fait du bien de te voir !
Je les ai faits moi-même.
C'est vrai, Stevie m'a aidée.
Si je peux faire un truc
pour vous réconforter, dites-le moi.
Où sont toutes nos "soeurs" ?
C'est jour de cérémonie.
Super.
C'est peut-être pas
le meilleur moment,
mais comme Katie n'est plus là,
j'ai bien un pied dans la place ?
C'est juste !
C'est la meilleure nouvelle
de toute la nuit !
Ou est-ce le jour ?
Je suis complètement perturbée !
Moi aussi.
Attends voir !
En y repensant,
tu peux nous aider.
Tout ce que tu veux.
Tu es bien restée à la fête
toute la nuit ?
Tout à fait !
Rien ne t'a paru bizarre ?
Je me rappelle pas grand chose,
j'étais plutôt cassée !
Ce n'était que la nuit dernière,
réfléchis !
D'accord !
Je vais me concentrer très fort.
Quand j'y repense...
ne m'en veux pas
de dire ça, Lana...
mais Jeff
avait un comportement bizarre.
Je peux me tromper,
mais je crois qu'il me draguait.
Ça me plaît pas de le reconnaître,
mais je l'ai surpris à flirter
avec deux nanas.
C'est une vraie ordure, parfois.
Je comprends pas
que tu tolères ça !
Il est quand même attachant !
C'est vrai qu'il est dingue de toi !
Assez pour tuer pour toi ?
Tu es une déesse, bébé !
Je ferais n'importe quoi pour toi !
Attendez !
Jeff a fait des trucs
vraiment étranges.
Comment ça, étranges ?
C'est un type bizarre.
Pendant toute cette semaine,
chaque fois qu'on a baisé,
il faisait d'étranges grimaces,
et se barrait tout de suite après !
C'est normal.
Non.
C'est pas ça qui en fait un tueur ?
Je sais pas, mais...
il n'est plus du tout
le même sexuellement.
La dernière fois que je l'ai croisé,
il faisait cette drôle de grimace.
Une minute !
Je l'ai vu sortir de ta chambre,
avec ce même air !
De ma chambre ?
T'aurais dû nous dire ça
il y a cinq minutes !
C'est pas vrai !
C'était Jeff !
Les filles, non !
C'est n'importe quoi !
Mon propre copain, le tueur ?
Bon sang, bébé !
Tu es fascinante !
J'ai pensé que tu aimerais !
On peut juste...
parler une seconde ?
J'ai un truc à te dire.
Quoi donc ?
Je suis amoureux de toi.
Je suis sérieux.
J'envisage un avenir avec toi.
Tu trouves ça idiot ?
Je sais pas quoi dire !
Je pensais que ça te ferait plaisir.
C'est vrai, seulement...
je suis encore bouleversée
à cause de ce cadavre.
Dis-moi juste...
ce que je dois faire
pour te rendre heureuse.
Prends ça !
Bâillonne-le
avec le soutien-gorge.
Attache-le bien !
N'aie pas peur de lui faire mal !
À présent, on parle !
On sait que tu as tué Katie.
Enregistre !
Je t'ai vu sortir
de la chambre de Lana.
Juste après ta dispute avec Lana,
c'est ça, Emily ?
Dis-nous la vérité !
Enlève-lui le bâillon.
Vous êtes complètement folles ?
J'ai un truc à confesser, mais...
Je le savais !
C'est pas ce que vous croyez !
J'ai rien à voir avec ce meurtre !
Vraiment ?
Bien sûr que non !
Je savais que mon chéri
n'était pas un tueur !
En fait, j'ai placé...
cette petite caméra,
pour filmer nos ébats.
Quoi ?
Comment j'aurais assez de fric
pour ton style de vie ?
Qui a vu le film ?
C'est pas lui le tueur ?
Attends, Zoey !
Une nouvelle ?
Quoi ?
Je pourrais te tuer !
Résous le crime
avant de le tuer !
T'as raison.
Jeff n'est pas un tueur,
mais un perverti du fric !
C'est juste.
Attends !
La caméra tourne sans arrêt ?
La plupart du temps.
Et la nuit dernière ?
Elle était en marche.
J'ai voulu récupérer le film,
mais y avait cette Katie,
recouverte de vomi, alors...
Où est la cassette de cette nuit ?
Dans la bouche de la peluche !
Reste ici jusqu'à
ce que je revienne.
Et tâche de dessoûler !
T'es un vrai désastre !
Dommage que t'aies passé
une si mauvaise soirée !
Je suppose
que tu veux plus rester ?
Tu rigoles ?
Je me suis tellement marrée !
C'est la plus belle
soirée de ma vie !
J'adore Omega Kappa !
T'es sérieuse ?
Absolument !
Génial !
T'es venue faire quoi ?
Oh, mon Dieu !
Me regardez pas comme ça,
vous me fichez la trouille !
- Comment t'as pu faire ça ?
- Vous êtes dingues !
- Fichez-moi la paix !
- Arrêtez-la !
Dégage de là !
Enlevez-moi ces menottes !
Faut que je trouve les clefs !
Emily, on veut juste discuter !
Quelle bande d'idiotes !
Vous êtes folles,
j'ai pas tué Katie !
On te fera pas de mal !
On veut juste
que tu parles aux policiers.
Tout se passera bien, Emily !
Magne-toi !
Debout !... Vas-y !
Sors de la maison !
J'arrive !
Je les ai trouvées !
- Dépêche-toi !
- J'essaie !
Garde la cassette,
je vais rallumer !
- Tu me laisses seule ?
- Oui !
On file les filles,
elles s'enfuient vers le nord.
Ouais !... Vas-y !
Attrape le ballon !
Remue-toi un peu !
Jaul, Santocki...
Réveillez-vous !
Le tueur est dans la maison !
Pas ma douce Emily !
C'est pour ton bien.
T'as besoin de quelque chose ?
Non, j'allais juste...
j'allais à la salle de bains.
Moi aussi, j'étais une héritière.
- Tu te souviens ?
- Oui.
Quand j'ai rejoint ce club,
j'ai pensé...
c'est ma chance
de me métamorphoser !
J'ai perdu du poids...
acheté de nouvelles fringues,
mais pour vous
je suis restée la godiche,
qui s'était infiltrée chez vous.
J'ai dû faire les corvées,
et même vos devoirs !
Pose ce couteau,
et on va discuter.
Y a rien à discuter.
Toi et toutes les autres,
vous me détestez !
C'est pas vrai.
On t'aime bien.
Tu es "Okay" !
Tu es la pire manipulatrice
que j'aie jamais connue !
Écoute-moi bien !
Je voulais que Katie s'en aille,
mais tu lui as pas permis,
elle s'amusait trop !
Tu m'écoutes !
Quand j'ai songé...
à tout ce qu'elle devrait endurer
pendant quatre ans...
j'ai décidé de la sauver !
De toi...
et de tes...
horribles petites pestes
de copines égoïstes !
Je suis désolée, je savais pas
que tu ressentais ça.
Mais ce n'est pas du tout
plus facile d'être moi.
C'est terrible de devoir être
toujours parfaite !
J'aimerais pouvoir manger
ce qui me plaît,
ou porter des lunettes,
au lieu de lentilles,
pas me décolorer les cheveux
toutes les 3 semaines !
Tu crois que cette vie m'amuse ?
J'aimerais être normale
rien qu'une fois !
Comme toi, Nina.
Mais dans mon univers...
ou celui de ma mère...
c'est hors de question !
En ce cas,
je vais te rendre service !
Arrête de frapper !
Je t'ai défendue !
Je sais, bébé.
Super de l'avoir arrêtée !
Elle me déteste,
et c'est une psychopathe !
Vraiment désolé
pour les cassettes.
Il faudra beaucoup
pour te faire pardonner.
Je sais.
La prochaine fois,
je veux la moitié du fric !
Ça marche, partenaire !
3 ans plus tard
Ça fait déjà trois ans ?
Bien. Petite mise à jour.
Emily est présidente du club,
sur mes traces glorieuses.
Zoey s'est sortie
de son addiction au sexe,
et n'est manifestement
plus obsédée par sa ligne.
Quant à Mai ?
Elle est fiancée !
Elle fera une mariée magnifique !
À moins que ce soit Rachel ?
Aucune importance.
Le mariage "gay" est mieux admis !
C'est Lana Stevens !
Je parie que vous voulez savoir
pour Jeff et moi ?
Disons simplement
que nos activités périscolaires...
s'avèrent extrêmement lucratives !
Pour nous deux.
Il est temps que nous rentrions !
Les "Soeurs OK"
ont beaucoup à se raconter.
Seigneur, ce que Zoey a grossi !
Et Mai qui est lesbienne !
C'est très gênant !
Je me demande
ce qu'est devenue Nina ?
Je suis "Okay" !
Quelle est ta couleur favorite ?
Rose pâle...
Plus fort !
Je suis "Okay" !
Sous-titres: Studios de Saint Maur
Adaptation: Laure Hurlin